[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Music]
okay visualpolitik fans i'm going to
start by setting you a challenge pay
attention to the following data imagine
that there is a country with inflation
above 50 every year where almost half of
the population lives in poverty a
country with very few quality jobs and a
chronic shortage of foreign currency and
investment a country that has been
experiencing a situation of almost
constant economic political and social
crisis for decades and that has fallen
far behind in terms of productive
technology come on things cannot
continue like this they are facing an
unsustainable scenario right a situation
in which it's time to sit down and make
some real decisions the question is if
you were in charge what decision would
you make
well i'm sure that with so many internal
problems one of the solutions that many
of you would put forward would be this
country must clearly turn to foreign
trade after all this would allow it to
earn a lot of foreign currency create
new jobs attract new investments acquire
new technologies new markets and a long
list of other benefits we are talking
about formula that has been used by many
governments around the world from spain
to japan poland china and singapore
however visual politic viewers there is
a country with many many many more
problems than those we have described in
this video in which the term
international trade is treated almost
like heresy i am of course referring to
argentina a country that seems to be
allergic to the outside world
but why is argentina so hostile to
foreign trade what are the obstacles how
could the land of tango and barbecues
convert foreign trade into an enormous
source of wealth in this video we're
going to answer all of these questions
but first first we have to see where all
of this started check this out
from globalization to isolation
argentina was a sparsely populated and
impoverished country until the 19th
century when an enormous social and
economic change took place the country
opened up to the world and millions of
immigrants and investments began to
arrive allowing the great expansion of
the human to pappas to be put to work
and so little by little argentina became
the granary of the world and also one of
the most prosperous countries on earth
the railroads transported to the ports
of rosario and buenos aires the produce
of the countryside obtained through the
hard work of the european immigrants who
had arrived in the country in search of
fortune in this way cities grew
investments accumulated and the country
had its own version of the american
dream however everything began to change
when the great crash broke out in 1929 a
crisis that originated in the united
states but soon spread to the rest of
the world
[Music]
argentina was no exception from that
moment on many pointed to international
trade open borders and the gold standard
as the key ingredients of the crisis
this provoked a huge wave of nationalism
interventionism and protectionism in
world politics and you know what
argentina was an outstanding student in
this very field
economic liberalism and agro-export
economy that had characterized the
gaucho country up until then were
considered an outdated model the
majority opinion began to lean towards
the country focusing on carrying out a
process of internal industrialization
that would allow it to succeed
independently of the fluctuations of the
international economy
[Applause]
these ideas were consolidated with the
outbreak of the second world war and
particularly with the coming to power of
juwan domingo peron in 1946
from that moment on the country would
gradually cut itself off from the global
economy following the so-called import
substitution policy a type of policy
that reached its peak in the 1970s in
fact one of the books that has most
influenced argentine economists is the
work entitled weaver con lo nestro
living with what is ours published in
the early 1980s by the so-called
argentine paul krugman that is ado
ferreira living with what's ours i mean
i don't really think that needs much of
an explanation the fact is that apart
from the brief interval of menem's
presidency which by the way we've
already covered here in visualpolitik
argentine politicians have worked hard
to isolate the country from the rest of
the world well the exception is if we
are talking about the international
monetary fund dollars in that case you
know the argentine politicians always
put their hand out first and then when
it is time to pay come up with a million
excuses
[Music]
argentina far from promoting exports has
raised all kinds of barriers to foreign
trade this is a completely paradigmatic
case in international politics and take
note because we are talking about a task
that politicians have taken very
seriously even when the results have
been calamitous not only have they not
changed course but they have stepped on
the accelerator and you know what that
is precisely what the current president
alberto fernandez is doing check this
out
in search of the dollar
the most surprising aspect of the
argentine case is not that politicians
have become obsessed with hindering
imports with the excuse of promoting
domestic industry and avoiding the loss
of foreign currency after all that is
something that many other governments
around the world have done and that by
the way always ends badly among other
reasons because competition and the use
of cheaper or more technology advanced
inputs are harmed while captive markets
are generated no the most striking thing
about the argentine case is that the
country is in desperate need of dollars
and then punishes its own exports yeah
that's what i said the argentine
government just keeps hindering foreign
transactions both buying and selling
basically if you are an argentine
business person and you want to trade
with foreign countries you are treated
suspiciously now the question is how
exactly does the state do it what
mechanisms does the argentine government
use to torpedo international trade well
you see currently the first factor is
capital controls that is in the rules
that the government has set for
argentines who want to buy sell and move
dollars which as you all know is the
reference currency for world trade these
controls have led to two exchange rates
in the gaucho country
on the one hand there is the official
exchange rate which at the time of
making this video was around 104 pesos
per dollar and on the other hand we have
the free exchange rate in the informal
market better known as the blue dollar
exchange rate where to give you an idea
the dollar costs twice as much about 220
pesos per dollar
of course all banking operations are
carried out taking into account the
official dollar which as we're about to
see is not so easy to obtain but let's
start by looking at what happens with
purchases that is imports
[Music]
any company large medium or small that
needs to import products from abroad
must face a long labyrinth of paperwork
and forms that will make it very
difficult to obtain the foreign currency
it needs you see in order to import
products companies have to obtain an lna
a non-automatic import license these are
licenses granted by the argentine state
in a totally discretionary manner in
other words getting one will depend on
whether the official on duty considers
that your request to buy abroad makes
sense or not and so the interested
parties are obliged to explain why and
for what purpose they want the foreign
currency request it well in advance and
pray that the official in charge of the
case will listen to their prayers and
grant them their much needed license if
not tough luck you're basically screwed
in this way the argentine government
controls the volume of imports entering
the country and if suddenly the foreign
exchange of the central bank is reduced
very fast the faucet is closed and many
more licenses than usual are rejected
although this of course means a very
harsh punishment for local companies
that overnight may face the inability to
obtain raw materials on products from
abroad that are necessary for their
activity
bad luck this explains why in argentina
it is common for companies to face
recurring shortages of materials which
for example may prevent them from
improving production or repairing a
machine so you see the official dollar
in argentina is cheap but it comes with
a hell of a catch but wait a minute if
you get along well with the government
voila you can have an inexhaustible
source of wealth why
[Music]
well because by setting an official rate
that has nothing to do with the market
rate what the government is doing is
basically subsidizing your purchases
abroad but i repeat only as long as you
have their blessing yes i know it's a
pretty awful system okay so this is true
for imports but what about exports and
foreign sales well visualpolitik fans if
you export a product and you get dollars
the government is going to forcefully
convert them into pesos at the official
exchange rate of course that is at 104
pesos per dollar and not at 220 which
was the price of the blue dollar at the
time of making this video
the problem is that argentina's economy
in the face of the peso disaster is
largely dollarized and so the cost of
companies are determined in many cases
by the exchange rate of the blue dollar
to put it another way when a company
decides to export its production what it
will receive are pesos and an exchange
rate that is half of what the dollars
that the government takes away from it
are worth in the market
remember that when an argentine company
wants to import something it benefits
from the cheap dollar the problem is
that in addition to having to pay a lot
of tariffs it is not guaranteed to have
access to dollars and when you want to
export well you end up only getting half
crazy or local as they might say this in
addition to taxes labor regulations and
well all kinds of obstacles in the
country explains why despite argentina's
low wage costs there are practically no
multinationals willing to invest in the
country to produce there and then sell
to the rest of the world because of
course given such an environment who
would do it but take note because this
is not the end of the story
[Music]
since these types of policies have
destroyed its industrial sector
argentina is mainly characterized by the
export of agri-food products such as
meat cereals and flour these products
are also consumed by argentines
themselves in order to prevent foreign
buyers from competing with local
consumers argentine companies face
maximum export quotas in other words the
government forces companies to sell a
considerable part of their production of
the local market at prices set by the
government itself this all may seem very
nice very considerate even the problem
though visualpolitik fans is that it
reduces foreign exchange inflows wages
and investment increasing productive
capacity the end result is bad for
everyone but then there's even more for
the last 20 years argentina's star
export has been soya beans a product
that is devoured in china but barely
consumed locally so here the export
quota is meaningless now do you think
this was going to stop the politicians
well if so you are very much mistaken
soybean producers can export as much
soybeans as they want but in return they
pay an additional tax an extraordinary
tax
while the blue dollar which is the free
dollar trades around 220 pesos soybean
exporters barely receive 70 pesos for
each dollar they export this is because
the government first converts the
dollars into pesos at the official
exchange rate and then imposes an
additional tax of 33
from 220 to 70 pesos per dollar exported
and take a deep breath because we're
still not done yet as if all of this
were not enough the government keeps
approving new barriers to make it
increasingly difficult to sell abroad
for example aggro exporters must be
registered in the so-called registry of
operators in the agri-food chain
something that forces them to deal with
a lot of paperwork for example they have
to make statements about the sales they
plan to make in the coming year submit
financial information to prove they are
solvent report in detail on their
employers and the salaries they pay
verify that the companies they interact
with also comply with the argentine
government's requirements and so on and
so forth in short it's a complete
nightmare
and then there's even more once it has
dealt with the government any company
that wants to export has to deal with
the control of two powerful unions that
of the truck drivers led by the moneo
clan and that of the port employees
suffice to say that the intervention of
these unions makes transportation in
argentina particularly expensive
competition limited and schedules and
service a disaster on top of that if you
don't get along with unions or you don't
pay them the jews they want forget about
it because they will probably stop the
shipment and you won't be able to do
anything with it
and these are just a few examples of
what day-to-day life is like because yes
being an exporter in argentina is almost
mission impossible and the data
corroborates this argentina's economy is
one of the most close to international
trade in the world it's a country that's
decided to do exactly the opposite of
what the most prosperous countries have
done exactly the opposite strategy to
the one that once made this country one
of the richest in the world but having
reached this point it's over to you with
all these obstacles would you consider
investing in argentina what do you think
explains the great obsession against
foreign trade leave us your answers in
the comments below and now if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like and subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik all the best and i'll see
you next time
[Music]